the voyage we're going to talk about
today began as a secret president Thomas
Jefferson had a plan one that he'd been
nurturing for years now the United
States was less than a generation old
and most of its people still lived
clustered in the original colonies along
the Atlantic coast in fact in the early
19th century an estimated two-thirds of
all citizens lived within 50 miles of
the Atlantic Ocean
yet Jefferson was convinced that the
destiny of the United States was to be
far larger continental in scale in other
words Jefferson had his eyes on the
great expanses of the West's places that
were then claimed by France Spain
Britain even Russia given that these
regions had not been mapped what
surprises might they still contain an
abiding fantasy that we've already seen
capturing the minds of many explorers
was the idea of a Northwest Passage a
great waterway cutting across the top of
North America giving access to Asia back
in 1611 Henry Hudson had died on a quest
for that voyage for that passage and no
one since had located it but perhaps
something like that might exist if not a
great waterway on a more modest scale
there might still be larger navigable
rivers that formed a network across the
North American interior that could be
exploited a network that would unite the
Atlantic with the Pacific and thus save
the long trip around the tip of South
America that Magellan had pioneered
centuries before so the prize might be
great the very fact that a Scotsman
named Alexander Mackenzie had already
crossed Canada from ocean to ocean in
1793 just made the matter even more
urgent Geoffrey Jefferson was convinced
that now was the time to find out by
whatever means necessary
so in mid-january 1803 Jefferson sent a
secret proposal to Congress Jefferson
urged that an expedition be funded by
the US government to travel beyond the
Mississippi River
beyond the boundaries of the United
States toward the Rocky Mountains to
chart and explore these areas most of
them claimed by France an American
officer and troops were to be sent out
to journey along the Missouri River to
get to know the local Native American
tribes and especially to try to locate
the Northwest Passage if it existed for
this undertaking Jefferson requested
that Congress authorize the vast sum of
$2,500 in spite of this huge expense
Congress agreed Jefferson urged that the
expedition be officially called a
scientific and literary undertaking so
as to mask its true geopolitical and
strategic importance and Jefferson
already knew who the leader should be of
that expedition a man he had chosen for
this task earlier and had actually
appointed as his own personal secretary
Meriweather Lewis the 29 year old Lewis
was like Jefferson a native of Virginia
he also had been an officer in clashes
with Native American tribes on the Ohio
frontier which was then the Wild West
Lewis was intelligent resourceful and
resilient so Jefferson believed that he
was the ideal man for the task sensing
to the challenge would be so large in
this undertaking that he would need help
Lewis also wrote to an old friend asking
if he would partner in leading the
expedition this was William Clark
another Virginia born Army officer who
had frontier experience in fighting the
Native Americans Clark was an
extroverted cheerful man with bright red
hair he was older than Lewis and in fact
had been his superior in the army but he
was now retired
Clark readily agreed and this proved to
be a most successful partnership once
the expedition began Lewis was formally
in charge but they worked as equals
something about their temperaments
complemented each other and they agreed
this human connection proved vital to
the success of the journey in April 1805
the Corps was ready at last to leave
Fort Mandan and resumed their journey
west in smaller boats for the leaders
this was an epic moment up until this
point they had traversed areas that were
known that were familiar to trappers and
at Fort Mandan they had been at the far
edge of the familiar from now on from
this point they were literally going off
the map into areas that were simply
unknown to them we've noted a theme in
our course of one set of journeys
prompting other journeys and here we can
actually see that inspiration very
clearly because Lewis as he sort of
savored and thought about this moment of
stepping off the map wrote in his
journal his thoughts this is what he
said
this little fleet although not quite so
respectable as those of Columbus or
Captain Cook were still viewed by us
with as much pleasure as those
deservedly famed adventurers ever beheld
theirs we were now about to penetrate a
country on which the foot of civilized
man had never trodden the good or evil
it had in store for us was for
experiment yet to determine